the area that we're standing in London
the south bank of the Thames was a kind
of entertainment zone you would come
here from different parts of the city
knowing that there were lots of
different things you could do on a given
afternoon you could pay a boatman to
take you across the river on his rowboat
drop you off here and then you could go
to the globe in front of which we're
standing or across the street to another
theatre at the Swan or you could walk
around in this area and go to there were
fields out beyond this zone with the
theaters were you could practice archery
you could go to one of the many houses
of prostitution that we're in this
neighborhood you could go to a tavern
you might go and see what we call bull
baiting and bear baiting exhibitions at
the time that is to say in in spaces
rather like this where Londoners liked
to watch a bull or a bear being attacked
by savage dogs they found this exciting
or amusing it was a practice that
continued right up until the English
Civil War when Puritan soldiers killed
most of the bears shot most of the bears
of London and they never quite recovered
from that but up until that time all
during Shakespeare's lifetime that was
an alternative entertainment in this
area there were lots of entertainments
possible in the city and particularly in
this part of the city because it was
much less controlled by the city
authorities than the area on the other
side of the river this area had been the
center of monasteries in the Middle Ages
and those monasteries had separate legal
arrangements from those that in the main
part of the city businesses and houses
had and that meant that certain things
could be done here that the city fathers
themselves didn't much like but that
they couldn't stop why did the city
fathers not like the theater which is
one of the glories
London at the time well there were lots
of reasons they didn't like it because
it was a traffic problem there were lots
of of carriages that came people riding
up on horses there was a legend in the
17th century the Shakespeare got his
start parking horses for people so it
was a kind of horse parking lot
attendant that everyone loved I don't
believe it but it's a story that
suggests that there were parking issues
at the time and then there were problems
with people taking off from work the
city fathers sober as they were thought
that it was not a good idea to have a
major entertainment industry that
dependent on people abandoning their
work and going off for the afternoon to
watch a play at the drink then they were
worried about prostitution they were
worried about the possibility of people
saying things that were not somehow
appropriate to be said that might be
subversive or seditious and then they
had the single biggest worry that is I
think something we need to take very
very seriously which was a public health
issue they worried especially about
bubonic plague and they had good reason
to worry about it there were all through
Shakespeare's lifetime and for that
matter before even in the year that he
was born outbreaks terrible outbreaks of
bubonic plague it that took away the
lives of very large numbers of people up
to a third of the population of the city
of small towns and cities could die very
very quickly from this extremely
communicable disease the city didn't
understand exactly the medical
authorities didn't understand exactly
what the disease came from but they
understood that it came it was
intensified by large numbers of people
being brought together so they thought
okay we're not going to tell people they
can't go to church because after all God
should protect people from communicable
diseases that way but the theatre No so
when the death rate reached a certain
number in London the city fathers would
shut the theatres down and they wouldn't
open them again and
the death rates declined below that
number and that happened actually
periodically during Shakespeare's
lifetime and caused major problems
economic problems for companies like
Shakespeare's and the other ones that
were in competition they would have to
figure out what to do to while away the
weeks and sometimes months and one
instance over a little more than a year
before the theaters could be reopened
you